the joint resolution is passed
Congress approves legislation that would
force the adoption of a tentative labor
agreement averting what could have been
a massive rail strike involving about
115 000 workers
[Music]
unions and railroad carriers came to an
agreement in September to avoid a strike
but four of the 12 rail unions rejected
that contract citing specifically a lack
of paid sick days but how can Congress
intervene in private contract
negotiations forcing unions to accept a
deal
thanks to the railway Labor Act which
was enacted in the 1920s Congress has
the authority to act to avoid any
Interruption to Commerce or operation
which specifically includes the
settlement of all disputes when it comes
to things like pay and working
conditions
Freight rail moves about 40 percent of
U.S long-distance cargo and delivers
Goods including coal grain and ethanol
and three-quarters of new cars and
trucks bought in the U.S are also moved
by rail industry analysis shows that if
a rail strike took place the U.S economy
would risk losing more than two billion
dollars a day
President Biden who has hailed himself
as pro-labor encouraged Congress to pass
the legislation
it's an easy call but I think we have to
do it the economies are risk members of
Congress however are divided over the
decision to intervene it's incumbent
upon Congress to do everything that he
can to protect these workers if you're
passing a bill to force the rail workers
to work
how strong is your economy
this isn't the first time Congress has
stepped in they've done it 18 times but
not since the early 90s when Congress
and President George H.W bush passed
legislation ordering workers back to
their jobs and then created mandatory
arbitration which has long alleviated
Congress from getting involved
but this time because that arbitration
wasn't agreed on Congress acted earlier
hampering workers ability to go on
strike and forcing the acceptance of the
agreement which will last until the end
of 2024.